it's safe to say you've been unlucky in  love unlucky in love you know I just I  just didn't know what love was I didn't  know I never saw it never experienced it  how do you date now carefully seriously  do you do because I mean I'm single too  and I'm out in the single girl struggle  is what I call it and people say well  what about online dating or whatever it  scares the heck of em well I'm not  having sex before marriage so you know  I'm dating very carefully right now I'm  dating a marine and he's off in Iraq and  I'm very proud very proud I see your  fella or are you guys just now he's my  men all right so where did you guys meet  at CPAC well there you go so you have a  man who is serving our country who is at  CPAC so he's a conservative just like  you Candace is happily ever after and he  wants to fight for peace for the world  he's actively doing it and so am I